ce journal fait décidément la part belle
aux activités nautiques puisque on
embarque à nouveau direction l'île aux
oiseaux alors l'île aux oiseaux c'est
une petite île secrète dans le bassin
d'arcachon un paradis naturel est un
lieu de mouillage rêvée pour tous les
plaisanciers reportage david bazille et
vincent dubroca
larguez les amarres souquer ferme en
avant tout c'est l'appel du grand large
pour les plaisanciers d'arcachon
destination de rêve l'île aux oiseaux et
ses cabanes tchanquées
l'île paradisiaque et à un quart d'heure
du port c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il y
a tant de vocations de captain cook pour
venir mouiller ou barboter dans le fin
du fin du bassin d'arcachon un village
de bateau avec son épicerie flottante où
l'on achète au bas de tout du tout du
tout il y en a qui sont vraiment l'été
reprise de de foie gras ou 10 buts ce
soir
il est si sympa l'épicier les gobelets
sont en plastique mais c'est tellement
mieux que saint-trop' le lubéron ou
monter car ce sacre est très agréable
très sympa et j'adore être là donc je
viens régulièrement exerçables suite de
l'escapade à bord d'une pinasse ce
bateau traditionnel d'arcachon est
maintenant un taxi qui emmène les
regards à la découverte des rivages
moins connus de lille une forêt de
curieuses cabane ville se dévoile mais
n'espérez pas la conquérir
de la prochaine et ce qui en fait le
charme
la phaser aussi
s'il y avait les
des trades des trucs pour
désormais nous on veut pas ça
inaccessible à moins de progresser
derrière philippe lurie cet
ostréiculteur a passé une enfance de
robinson sur l'île le guide idéal à
travers une végétation 100 chemin
direction les cabanes construites par
les premiers à s'être posé là les
ostréiculteurs comme bien sûr avant
c'était tout se faisait à la rame ça
leur permettait de partir depuis l'île
de tranquillement sur leur parc situé à
proximité de l'île maintenant forcément
sont devenus cave en villégiature au
combien prise est brisée désiré convoité
au point qu'on propose des fortunes pour
acquérir ces cabanes les ostréiculteurs
essayent de résister pour vivre heureux
vivons cachés quitte à être méfiants
envers les visiteurs fois que vous avez
des justes des jumelles ses ventes
en faire la matière il a marre et
ordonne le moment du départ
lamari qui rend les visites fnr pour que
brille encore le trésor de toute une
profession